Like there's a whole network of them,
you know,
I've done Doug Benson's and Duncan trussell's and Duncan will be on the show
tomorrow at three o'clock you know,
and did Mark Marin's and it's a,
I'm going to do Eddie F and M,
Jim Jefferies.
So like doing all these podcasts,
it's like,
you know,
it's like there's this cool network of radio stations that's happening
organically,
you know,
instead of like Bubba the love sponge and you know,
the Farell show all being stuffed into one thing by a corporation.
Like everybody's kind of found themselves and become like this network sort of
organically.
You know,
it's cool.
like fans of one we'll hear about the other,
you know,
like Duncan Trussell got some fans when,
when you know,
he came and did this podcast and I came and did his and you know,
we share each other's listeners and stuff.
It's,
it's really a fucking,
a very unique thing.
You know,
the,
this podcasting,
and as we said,
it probably wouldn't have happened if it wasn't for Adam,
you know,
him,
him.
And I'm also an Anthony Kumina from opie and Anthony because Anthony was doing
that lie from the compound thing and that was green and Tom Green.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Can't forget Tom Grant.
Tom Green,
uh,
doing his,
his show on Tom green.com,
which,
yeah,
I don't think it does anymore.
I,
yeah,
I'm not really sure what he does anymore.
I think he went to some kind of subscription based things,
so I kind of,
I don't know.
Did you hear completely getting off subject?
Did you hear what happened in Afghanistan?
The Taliban escaping out of the prison?
No.
What happened,
dude?
Some guy tweeted me this thing and the guy who tweeted it,
it was really funny.
He said,
uh,
and a referee,
let's fucking,
what was his exact quote?
I don't want to fuck up this guy's quote because it was such a funny situation.
Um,
they,
uh,
they dug 450 Taliban fighters w escaped out of,
here's what he wrote.
He wrote 450 plus prisoners break out of jail by digging a hole in the ground
and homage to bugs bunny and raising Arizona.
The guy's name is Gary with two r's,
whoever.
And uh,
so I retweeted it and then I,
uh,
read the,
the link and it is pretty fucking fascinating.
These guys dug a hole in the ground,
like a fucking movie and went under the prison and got all the guys out of
prison.
Wow.
Yeah.
Did,
uh,
did they catch him?
No,
no.
I mean,
not yet,
but I mean,
just the whole thing and Afghanistan is,
I mean,
who's the fucking bad guy over there and no escape.
They were all murdered.
These fucking guys are running around with sandals on and the in the,
in the mountains and you know,
we've got drones flying overhead,
taking pictures of him shooting missiles and the hundreds of thousand,
who knows how many thousands of fucking soldiers over there?
Who's the bad guy?
I don't know.
It gets a little fucking blurry.
Right.
You know,
I don't know.
I mean,
you know,
they're,
they're evil terrorists and they're attacking the Americans.
Well,
what are we doing over there?
you don't think you could.
You think you can just come into someone's neighborhood.
They don't fucking shoot at you.
You can't just take over.
And then when you take over,
people fight back and when they fight back,
well,
who's the fucking bad guys?
It's some kid who was born in Afghanistan and this is only knows,
and this is the,
the neighborhood he grew up in and all of a sudden he sees he's fucking
helicopters,
fly overhead and tanks rolling around on the ground.
What would you think you think you'd been invaded and the bad guy?
It's,
it's very,
very tricky man.
I mean,
I obviously never would want anything bad to happen to any of our troops
overseas,
but I also don't want them to do anything bad to all these fucking people
either.
The whole thing's a cluster fuck.
Who knows how many people have become terrorists because of all the shit that
we've done overseas.
Who am I?
Who knows how many people lost family members whom I know,
who knows how many people who would have been like a sort of a moderate person
who really,
you know,
wouldn't get into this kind of stuff,
got drawn into it because a tragedy got drawn into it because you,
someone they'd know or they get to watch,
you know,
video footage when you're dealing with shit like what's going on in Iraq,
dude,
there's like a million dead people over there over the course of the nine years
of this war or whatever.
It's been.
Million people have died.
That's an insane number of people.
I mean,
if you stacked a million bodies up in the,
in the middle of like Washington state park and had everybody look,
here's everyone that's died in Iraq,
maybe then it would sink in.
Maybe then people would really kind of realize how crazy war is in fact that
this is really how we have to do things in 2011 you know what's crazy is that I
didn't know about that and it would seem that that's something I should know
about.
You know a million people died in Iraq.
No,
no,
no.
About this new story you did,
but the other day I'm eating and it's like we have breaking news here and now
we're going to go live downtown Los Angeles.
Lindsay Lohan is going to jail.
Let's re let's interview this sheriff and Blah Blah Blah.
And then it was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
Why?
What?
They spent like five minutes on it and then you go,
all right now for another top news story today,
the wedding of the century,
and it's those people that are getting married in the UK,
the prints or whatever.
Have you heard about this shit?
I've very peripherally saw it's about it.
Every single news channel here in the United States and I,
why do I care about some prints getting married?
Like why is this?
Because people love gossip.
The news has become like people magazine.
I mean when you're talking about two wars going on,
plus Libya plus actions in Pakistan with drones,
there's a lot of crazy shit going on every fucking day of the week.
A lot of it.
If you're hearing anything at all about Lindsay Lohan and she hasn't killed 50
people.
I know there's something wrong and I didn't know more about Lindsay Lohan than I
do about fucking all these distributors.
Do you think that that is because that the networks are trying to,
you know,
make the,
the,
the easiest to digest sort of programs after people are tired from work and just
give them,
give the dummies what they want.
Is it because the dummies want this or it's because that's the only thing that's
on the air is it,
they have a mentality that people are dumb.
And in pushing all this Lindsay Lohan,
Shit,
look,
here's the thing,
man.
I can get into it too.
You know,
I,
I understand it.
I mean,
I don't judge people for like,
Mrs Rogan likes to gossip magazines sometimes.
She likes it,
like reading about things every now and then.
And uh,
you know,
and I don't,
I,
I make fun of it.
I make fun of it,
but I'll fuck if I'm taking a shit,
I'll start reading it,
you know,
and I'll start reading.
Damn,
we just left it like that.
And what is she doing?
Oh man,
she's fucking that guy now.
Whoa,
this is crazy.
And now she's got a baby.
I bet he's mad.
You know,
it's,
it's easy.
We have instincts to gossip and we have instincts to,
to follow,
you know,
silly fucking stories in the news.
Whether it's about the princess or especially when it's royalty.
That's when it's so squirrelly.
It's like that prince,
that guy doesn't do shit.
He doesn't do shit.
He's a prince.
I mean,
he hasn't done anything.
He hasn't been elected.
He hasn't written some awesome books that everybody loves.
This guy has only famous because he's a prince.
I mean,
that's just fucking completely insane.
That's that when you get into royalty,
it's the ultimate form of celebrity in entitled celebrity for no reason.
At least Kim Kardashians suck some Dick.
You know what I mean?
And he's can masturbate to that.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
everybody talks about how Kim got the oceans become famous over nothing sort of,
but no,
no.
So you became famous because she lent that black guy fucked the shit out of her
on camera.
Yeah,
but she is now making millions and millions and millions of dollars and then you
have like these girls work in like Joanna Hayes that's not making millions and
millions of millions of dollars and she pretty much does the same shit.
She did it once.
She did it once and it was her boyfriend and then it caught on quite God out.
Who knows what their family's making?
17 what million?
Who knows how much?
It's a lot of money.
They're making a lot of money.
She's everywhere.
But who you know?
Who knows who the fuck put that video out.
You can't really,
maybe she did.
Maybe she did.
Maybe he did.
Who knows?
Maybe someone else got ahold of it.
But the the,
the point is if we,
even if we knew like that you put it out on purpose,
it's okay still.
It's like people gas.
As long as you say that you didn't put it on purpose,
you get a pass.
But if you do put it on purpose,
if you make a porno video on purpose,
you fuck on camera on purpose,
you don't get in.
Isn't that strange?
No,
he is not going to give you a fucking TV show.
You know?
You're not going to get nothing unless it's a TV show on porn and it makes you
want to cry,
you know?
But then keeping up with the Kardashians doesn't make you want to cry.
You know?
You've watched like one of those inside pieces on Bella.
Donna,
did you ever watch that?
Show it down?
They said it made you want to cry,
right?
Definitely.
Yeah.
I'm glad she's retired now.
Hopefully.
Maybe he's happy and he was,
she was happier when she's taking baseball.
Fascinating.
I was probably ahead.
Look,
it takes all kinds of people do to make this world go round.
Yeah,
but for,
it is a weird thing though,
that you're allowed to do it as long as you at least claim that you did it on
accident,
that it got released on accident.
But if we suspect that you put it out on purpose,
you actually made your own sex video and released it.
Yeah,
I think or I think it's pretty easy to get a video out nowadays because I've,
I've been realizing how many recordings now I've made of myself that I just
accidentally tweet.
The other day I accidentally tweeted something that I thought was a direct
message out to everybody and then I was like,
wow,
that's close.
I caught it right away
and my was a,
uh,
a video.
A video was a video,
some sexy time,
but yeah,
no,
no.
It was a video of,
it could've been sexy time.
It was cheesy video,
like a cheesy like,
oh,
just make a video together and accidentally put it out.
You know,
like I was trying to delete it,
Huh?
Yeah.
I deleted right away.
There's only one person supposedly that commented on it,
but like 170 people solid and,
and I'm like probably luck if there's just one person in there that grabbed that
video,
that would have been an awful,
how embarrassing is the video?
It's not that embarrassing.
It's just gross.
Gay.
You said it's not that you list when you sit
down bear thing,
you,
you like submitted to yourself.
You crawled inside of yourself.
It creeped me out.
When I saw,
when I realized I did it,
I was like,
well,
give us the cliff notes version of what's on the video.
Uh,
being,
uh,
we did,
I didn't want to play it.
At least I don't have it on,
but you know,
I deleted it.
I,
once I get it off everything,
I can embarrass him.
Well,
give me the cliff notes.
It was like,
I'm laying in bed at seven in the morning and my girlfriend's like laying on top
of you.
Make like wake up,
wake up and like,
oh,
I love you girl.
You know,
Shit.
Like,
Oh,
I love you girl.
You talked to her.
I don't know exactly how it talks to her and pretend you're in a movie.
I love you baby.
If you don't know how to deal with checks,
maybe that's the best way to do it.
Just pretend you like in a Tom cruise movie.
I did.
We did another blackout podcast and it was,
we started drinking at like midnight,
we got,
we drank a whole bottle of vodka and two huge glasses of great vodka.
Oh Shit.
And an hour.
And so it to me and Veronica Richie and it,
but what's so hilarious,
it starts off Ronica Richie girl is a penthouse pet.
Yeah.
But at the beginning of it,
it was really awkward conversation because he's super shy,
super shy,
family shot.
Her whole family's really shy.
People just fucking each other.
Right.
Is that what's going on?
I asked that.
That's how drunk became,
and then there was one point where she,
she,
she went stand up and she fell and did like a backflip.
So winning me,
you've known this chick for awhile and that's the only time you've ever talked
to her about molestation?
He did it on,
yeah.
Yeah,
it was pretty,
pretty great.
Did she respond?
You said,
listen to it.
I don't have that kind of time.
Just giving me what happens.
Uh,
she's uh,
I don't know.
I don't remember.
I blacked out.
She'd been molested.
Dude,
please.
You remember I blacked out.
She say she's been most of it.
I don't remember.
I blacked out.
That's ridiculous.
You're the worst actor ever.
So Bob,
I swear to God,
I haven't listened to re listen to it because I don't really listen to me.
I don't sit around,
sit around,
listen to my fucking self again.
I don't get it.
So all the soap operas,
man,
I know they can't.
Can they cancel two big ones the other day,
uh,
at when they canceled the hospital went last year.
Say,
why do I know about those soap operas,
Muslim,
the opera is awful.
It might as well be opera.
Like what are you doing?
Something that's old and stupid.
All right.
And the idea that you're going to have this crazy running drama every day and
like what's going to happen?
And she comes home and finds him with her and just every day there's drama and
crazy music.
And what a weird
way to live man.
Fucking stone Joe.
Hell yeah,
you are.
The two volcanoes got back in,
you die.
He dove right back in.
Sunn o w dove in just an hour ago and you dove right back in.
Have you ever tried one of the fake the volcanoes?
That's like a,
a copy of it,
like a generic copy of the volcano?
No I haven't.
It's called like uh,
the wave or something.
I forget what it's called but I just wondered if you,
cause it's only $90 compared to whatever the volcano is,
like $400.
I don't know.
I wouldn't go budget on vaporizers.
Yeah,
it seems like complicated man.
It seems like there's a lot of shit go on there and electricity and it's heat
and anytime just heat I say you got to get the best thing cause you don't want
things burning through the fucking cord and blowing up in your house or
whatever.
Some cheap piece of shit would do just get,
get the stuff that's going to work.
And that the volcano thing,
what we're talking about is a vaporizer and would vaporizing is ladies and
gentlemen is for the health conscious amongst us,
the stoners that don't want any of those bad nasty bits that you take in from
burning smoke,
which apparently is not nearly as bad for you as tobacco smoke.
But it's gotta be somewhat bad for you.
It's just smoke.
I mean,
I don't know.
It does.
It has some health benefits.
It's an expectorant and apparently it's very good for people when they have
asthma,
people have asthma,
at least some of them have reported that they have a,
a benefit from uh,
from small gangs,
from smoking the pot.
But with the vapor I does is it cuts out all the health problems.
It just,
it heats it up but doesn't burn it.
So,
and it blows air through it and it releases this THC missed and that is
collected.
And one of these,
and what this is,
is a,
you hear it iTunes folks,
it's a plastic bag at the end of it.
It has this whole novel and you just suck out the pure THC.
And if you suck out enough,
you can see aliens.
And by the way,
the volcano,
I've tried every single kind of vaporizer known to man.
And the volcano is the only one that I recommend.
If you're going to get one,
get the volcano because that shit works where the other ones you have to,
you're trying to adjust the temperature.
Right.
And sometimes it feels like you're not getting anything.
Then other times it's like you got too much dark smoke for some reason.
All that shit is just too ridiculous.
Just the volcano does it.
Yeah.
It just figures out how it works.
But I see how people don't want to pay that money.
Much money to get home.
I was on craigslist looking in.
There was a lot of those generic ones on it.
You know the only reason why all this shit cost so much cause it's illegal.
It's the only reason.
The only reason everything costs so much because it's illegal.
Marijuana should be cheapest.
Fuck,
it's a plant.
It's easy to grow.
It's a God damn weed.
It doesn't even get sick.
It doesn't rot.
You know,
you were like,
look at some trees and there's bugs.
Fucking them up.
Box.
Don't fuck up.
Re first pitch.
You didn't even have a chance.
Bugs and have a chance.
Reefer doesn't need pesticides.
Like people always say what happened?
Did they put pesticides?
You Weed,
man.
You like DDD poisoning bro.
That's what's wrong with weed.
No,
you don't need it doesn't need pesticides.
It doesn't get sick.
It's not like all these pussy ass plants.
It's one of the toughest plants that's ever existed.
It's the best fiber,
the fiber that you make at a hamp,
like when you make hemp jeans or clothes or,
but it's not.
It's like so much more sturdy than cotton and the paper,
like hemp paper is so superior to cotton,
it all became illegal.
Most people don't even know this,
but we came illegal back when they figured out a more effective way to process
the hemp fiber.
It was legal forever,
but it became like something that people stopped using because cotton became so
much more easy to process.
They came up with the cotton gin and instead of just having slaves pick the
cotton,
which was a huge pain in the ass,
then they could run it through this fucking machine and it made it way easier.
And so people were like,
fuck this hemp,
because hemp fibers like really tough stuff and you got to break it down.
Have you ever watched like manual breaking down of hemp fiber?
It's a laborious process,
men,
because the fucking stock of this plant,
this is like an animal or an alien planet rather.
It's an incredible plant.
Like it's the fibers like super fucking tough and strong.
You make the best rope out of it,
the best cloth out of it.
It's like so superior,
but it takes a long time to turn that fiber into cloth or paper.
It's really difficult to break down.
And then in like the early 1930s a guy came out with a machine called a
decorticator and with the decorticator did was allow them to process it just
like the cotton gin processes.
Cotton allows it to smash it down into this,
this pub and make it more much more usable,
like almost immediately.
And then that's when they said,
fuck this,
and that's when pot became illegal.
Palm became illegal entirely because of hemp,
which has nothing to do with the psychoactive properties.
It became illegal because of William Randolph Hearst who was running newspapers
and he also had paper mills and they were going to make people start using hemp
paper.
That was going to be the shit because you could,
you could tank like a forest full of trees and you chop them down when you're
fucked because you don't have any more trees.
Yeah.
It takes a long ass time for those trees to grow back.
But hemp,
you grow it every four months.
You'd have a new fucking crop.
I mean,
you could use the same property over and over and over again.
It's renewable and you get much more paper pull.
So this motherfucker was going to have to spend millions of dollars.
So them and Dupont,
William Randolph,
Hearst and dupont,
they got together and they said,
hey,
we will do,
we'll fucking say that pot makes um,
blacks and Mexicans rape white chicks.
And that's all they did.
That's what they did.
That's literally what they did.
They started printing stories.
William Randolph Hearst did in the paper of this new drug called marijuana and
what marijuana was,
had nothing even to do with pot.
The original name for marijuana was a slang for a wild Mexican tobacco.
So they call it marijuana and then say blacks and Mexicans are smoking
marijuana.
So when congress made hemp illegal,
when they made a marijuana illegal,
Dee Dee didn't even know they were making hemp illegal as well.
They fucked everybody and they did it.
19 fucking 30 something.
It's amazing that that shit is still going on.
It's still illegal in the age of the Internet.
We're all,
the information is at your disposal.
Everything you can Google search,
every fucking study ever done on pot,
and you could see right away that most people want it legal.
Who's stopping it?
Oh,
people with money.
Why they stopped doing it?
Well,
because they're making money on marijuana being illegal and they're using that
money that bribing politicians,
and that's how they keep it in place.
Fuck,
really?
In 2011 you can be that open.
It's that open where you can see so clearly.
It's so sick,
man.
It's sick.
It's sick that we live like this.
It's sick that you can put people in jail for Dwight and a smoke a joint and
kick back and listen to some good music and you know,
eat some food and have some great conversation with friends and not hurt
anybody.
And yet cops can come and lock you up in a fucking cage for that.
It's ridiculous.
We know what drugs are bad folks.
We know we have to stop letting people tell you that the drugs that are good or
bad because they're fucking wrong.
There's ones are bad.
Don't do math,
don't do heroin.
Or if you do,
you've got to be a musician or something,
you know,
heroin seems to be okay for musicians.
Did you see kills you?
Did you see that guy a bat?
What's his name?
Batiste.
Those Strikeforce guy.
Did you see how as a thing on TMZ other day?
No,
he uh,
he was talking about how his deal got cut,
you know,
from the merger with the UFC and the strike force and stuff like that.
Do you think that's something,
do you know anything about this guy or no,
I know anything more than a,
I saw there was a headline on mma.tv or mixed martial arts.com.
Yeah,
I saw that,
but I didn't read it.
It's not interesting to me.
Not Interested.
No,
not really.
I mean,
he seems like a nice guy and I wish them well,
but you know,
I'm interested in young guys that are coming up and I mean,
occasionally a guy like Lester Lester was like a serious wrestler,
you know,
like you're serious amateur wrestler.
Like that's what made him excited.
It wasn't just that it was a big guy.
Is this guy now?
I don't believe so.
I don't know.
I'm,
I really don't know his background,
but I feel like I would have heard about him the way I heard about Lesnar when
lesbian was a wrestler and we got back when he was doing pro wrestling,
I had heard about what a freak he was.
Like people were,
were talking about what a crazy specimen this guy was.
Dude,
there's a fucking video of him.
Uh,
we've talked about in the podcast before,
but it's worth,
it's worth repeating.
Just,
it's so ridiculous.
He was 300 pounds solid muscle,
right?
He gets on top of the fucking turnbuckle or whatever the hell it is,
stands on the ropes and flips through the air and lands on his head.
Lans I his fucking head.
He flew through the air and landed on his head and he was still conscious and he
climbed on top of the guy.
It's still got the pin and you watch it.
If you watch it,
you watch them do that and go,
that's supposed to kill people.
How did that not kill him?
Who's this guy?
How could,
how the fuck did that guy survived that?
It's supposed to snap your neck and break every fucking bone in your spinal
column.
It's supposed to be just chaos for you after that.
Meanwhile,
he liked finishes.
The match is ridiculous.
So he was already this guy where people are like this Brock Lesnar guy,
man,
you ain't never seen a heavyweight move like that guy.
And we had heard about his fucking times and that was like one of the things
they talked about during his wrestling days was his times in the NFL combine.
You know,
the NFL combine is,
you know,
it's like,
um,
I actually can pull up the numbers because it's so ridiculous.
It's,
it's worth reading.
But the NFL combine,
it's when they take athletes and they,
um,
you know,
they run them through these tasks like the 40 yard and you know,
see how fat,
let me find it real quick here.
I'm going to say something completely.
Stoney Brock and Shane,
here it is.
Here.
Let me read this to you right here.
This is his,
his crazy fucking numbers.
The 40 yard sprint,
4.6 seconds.
He's 200 and fucking 90 something pounds.
Okay.
4.6 seconds.
That's like eight times.
Fascinating.
You can do,
I mean,
stop and think about that.
40 yards of 4.6 seconds.
That's a fast 4,225 pound bench press,
43 repetitions,
43 of two 25.
What the fuck is vertical jump?
35 inches is broad jump 10 feet.
He hurls 300 pounds,
10 feet through the fucking air.
That's ridiculous shit,
dude.
That's a freak.
You know?
So we had heard about that shit like when,
when he was around,
we'd heard about that long ago and so when I heard that he was going to go into
a to to MMA,
I was like,
oh,
I was there for his first fight.
I saw this first went live.
It was at a la at the coliseum.
It was for a k one took his fucking dude down,
just smashed him.
And I remember looking at that going,
who's going to fuck with that?
Like that's a dangerous motherfucker.
Some freaky guy who can get on top of you and just punch your brains in and try
stopping it.
Good Luck,
you know?
Of course,
you know Cain Velasquez eventually did stop it,
but he was another,
another freak specimen.
When is it?
When's the rematch for that?
Well,
it's not going to happen unless Brock gets by a junior.
Dos Santos that's going to be in June junior dos Santos and him are coaching the
season of the ultimate fighter and then they're going to meet up in June.
I was Brock's training right now.
Have you heard anything about,
I haven't heard anything other than he's back with Greg Nelson who is the guy
who,
uh,
runs a ministry,
Minnesota,
a mixed martial arts and he's awesome.
I'm a big fan of that guy.
I'm a big Fan of his,
his coaching and his,
you know,
he does great worries,
formulates good game plans.
He's a real student of the game and you know,
he's,
he's fighters are all always well trained,
you know,
all of his guys very smart and well trained.
He handled shirk and he's got,
you know,
a couple of the young guys coming up like,
um,
the fuck's his name.
The guy that just wanted decision.
Fuck,
I hate that.
Opened up a Gracie to kill the Carney.
Um,
what's that?
They opened up at Gracie Jujitsu in Burbank right down the street from me.
Didn't,
are you gonna join?
No.
Why not?
I took a photo of it.
That's pretty funny.
I dude,
get in there.
Take a woman's class,
take spin class.
Got a crazy spin.
Have you been at Gracie spin yet?
Took the woman's class,
dude.
Step a they x.
They have ribbons.
Remember those ribbons with the sticks given shape?
Girl,
you used to do that.
You used to tell me all the time he used to do get in shape.
Girl.
By the way,
have you seen this?
That guy,
did you ever watch that guy's animation that he did for Burke crushers?
A staples video?
No.
Uh,
or win or a Barnes and know when he used to work out in the basement of that
bookstore as somebody put it to animation.
The same guy that did the first line.
Fucking brilliant.
You got to watch it.
Yeah,
the guy,
he's great.
Fuck.
Am I listening to you man?
You got to do a women's classes that's been getting in shape with pink Kimono on
and,
and just look like a dyke.
Shave your face.
That's what am I to just go on and say you're a dyke.
It's one way to do,
they allow transgender and the women's classes.
I'll give you more a man and you decided to become a woman.
Do they allow you to take a woman's class?
Yeah.
Well you're allowed to when you get postop or whatever.
Even if you're not fully,
you're allowed to go to the woman's restroom.
Are you rolling?
Yeah.
Postop or whatever.
You know what the supposedly was behind that woman getting beat up in that
Mcdonald's?
Uh Oh my God.
Did you hear about that?
It's fucking crazy.
Supposedly.
That's a transvestite.
Really?
Yeah.
That's what Amanda dresses like a woman.
I that's,
that's crazy that we know about Mcdonald's.
Well,
that video is huge.
I haven't seen the video part.
You haven't seen it?
No.
It was pretty ruthless.
Cross beat the fuck out of that girl and they keep going back.
They keep kicking him and then a girl kicks her when she's down kicks boots are
in the hand and the girl starts convulsing.
Oh God.
Yeah.
It's pretty rough.
And people would call it so fuck.
It looks so fake.
Tell you what,
it wasn't fake,
that big gigantic kick to the head.
That shit was real.
You know,
it's very possible and people don't know.
People go into convulsions.
So it's very possible that someone can have a seizure from heavy brain trauma
like that.
Very possible.
Don't think it's not,
you know,
the girl really kicked her in the head like it was,
it was really stumped her head,
you know,
it was pretty rough.
And uh,
you know,
the manager is trying to keep the girls off of the,
he can't,
he's in effective,
everybody got fired.
The whole thing.
It's pretty crazy.
But the idea was that she was a,
a he,
she and she was going into the woman's room.
That's what I read.
Whether or not that's true,
I haven't,
I don't know if they've interviewed her and got the whole full deal.
See,
this is like another form of soap opera.
You know,
Antwan Dodson,
he got arrested for marijuana possession.
Did you hear?
Did He,
yeah,
Ron and tell him that home home home boy somewhere in Alabama.
What's it doing in Alabama is probably where he lives.
No,
I thought he moved back to La.
I heard that he was living in la now and they were filming a new show with a
mallet.
Yeah.
Maybe it went back home and say hi to the homeys and they got busted.
Hi.
How amazed.
Oh,
oh yeah.
Back then man,
you still can get busted back there rather back there is back then.
That's funny because I said back then,
you know meaning like Alabama,
but it is back then in time as well,
you know,
I mean that's really what it is.
I'm saying back then because I'm thinking of it as it being in like the fifties,
you know,
I should've said back there,
but back then is more appropriate.
They live in a fucking time warp.
Yeah.
Stupid ass place where you can get fucking arrested for.
Oh,
did you hear about the Rhode Island Guy?
Here's another one I love hearing about politicians to get fucked up.
This guy who is a,
um,
he was a anti Marijuana House minority leader,
Robert Watson.
He was arrested for alcohol and drug charges.
They pull homeboy over and uh,
he failed the sup,
the field sobriety test.
So then,
um,
they,
uh,
they grabbed him and they searched his pockets and they find out he's got a,
a plastic bag filled with pot and a wooden pipe.
So this fucking dummy who is this anti pot guy gets busted with pot,
you know,
and that to me,
you,
that's like a gay guy who secretly gay votes against gay marriage and that they
should be,
they should be locked up.
You're,
that's like a,
you're like a trader.
You're like a trader for humanity.
Like you're a bad person.
Like if you really want to lock people in jail for pot and yet you enjoy pot,
you're a shitty human being.
You're willing to put your own personal gain ahead of the betterment of the
people.
You,
you're willing to take something that you know is not right and push it because
you think more people are gonna agree with you because it's the contemporary
opinion,
you know,
that's a,
that's a really shitty human being.
That guy,
you know,
I hope that guy is ostracized from the political community for life.
I hope they never allow him back.
And it's sad,
but they probably will.
He'll probably eventually show up somewhere else and apologize or become a
Christian or,
or something stupid and,
and they'll,
they'll suck them right back in.
Enough people will believe in him that he'll get some shitty job at some shitty
little fucking community where they won't bother Google search and what a Douche
bag he is.
You know,
hopefully it gets I herpes,
I think that that should exist where you can get herpes on your eyeball really
and breaks out like once,
once a month or whatever.
Whenever it happens.
I heard of a story and I don't know if it's true.
So Internet do your research.
A wrestler was on a,
uh,
in the middle of a match.
His contact fell out,
put his contact back in his eye,
got staff from the contact lens and died.
Is this true?
I have no idea.
This could very easily be one of those urban myths.
But,
uh,
I heard the story and I was like,
that is the scariest fucking thing I've ever heard in my life.
You know,
you eyeball staff that winds up killing you just because a contact lens fell on
the ground and the ground is so fucking polluted,
you know,
there's so much funk and fucking human slime on that ground.
That staff is some scary shit man.
I Hammer.
How scary like websites like rotten.com used to be there.
What was the one,
the other one that was really bad?
Uh,
not rotten.com.
That was the one I had like the red and black and I don't remember what you're
talking.
I remember I would be scared to go there.
There was a few,
there's a few sites to this day that I won't fuck with,
but somebody posted up a video the other day of a,
a Mexican lady cutting some dude's head off now I watched the whole time.
I Dunno.
That was weak as weak.
You shouldn't have done it.
They would,
they'd,
she,
she didn't just cut off as hatch to do a lot of other shit to him too.
And there's a video of it and they,
they show the guy dying.
I mean,
they show her.
And um,
I was amazed at how,
how much I've gotten over the impact of those things.
You know,
it used to be,
I would watch that and it would haunt my dreams.
Like the first time I ever saw faces of death and I realized he's a really,
bodies like faces death.
Some of the faces of death were,
um,
I don't know if it was exactly faces of death,
but one of those type of videos,
I remember one of them was super disturbing.
It was in some Middle Eastern country where they were killing a guy by tying him
in between two trucks and pulling them.
Oh yeah.
Remember the blood orgeat that was completely fake.
Right.
I don't remember that.
The blood orgy was,
they had a body in the middle and they were like,
Oh yeah,
that was fun.
It looked fake as fuck.
Yeah,
that looks stupid.
Train chick was the one that scared me.
The old,
the girl steps in for the train and get smashed.
Oh,
Marty flies towards the camera.
Oh my God,
that's hard.
I forgot about that train one man.
I forgot about that train one.
Ooh,
monkey brains.
Monkey brains is rough.
Yeah,
but I'll tell you what.
That's a monkey.
I don't really care that much about a month.
Tell me.
I'm not happy that a monkey dies.
But you want to see monkeys get fucked up.
Watch the chimps.
Fuck up the monkeys.
You know that's the most disturbing monkey shit online.
I'm just watching chimps eating monkeys while they're alive.
So monkey brains.
I don't even know if that was real.
Yeah.
Who knows.
I used to have a face of the death.
I've talked about this.
Maybe not in the podcast.
The UFC.
Do you have cause and that was our scary tape.
Like we be like guys,
they got USC number two in fear or whatever,
the faces of death.
So we'd go and watch that shit.
Yeah,
they used to disturb the shit out of me.
Like that video,
the guy's getting pulled to get pulled apart by the trucks that,
that fucking haunted me for days.
But now I can watch it and it's like,
it's so much easier to digest.
My favorite one was not my favorite,
the most disturbing one where that guy gets shot in the stomach and gut or
whatever it was.
Ooh,
la La and he falls down.
I didn't see that one.
You didn't?
Oh that,
that was one of the best of the,
I think it was faces of death too.
It was like a guy.
Yeah.
He goes and he falls down and we used to always say that,
oh,
growing up,
whenever I,
whatever bug doors,
the most disturbing or whatever he was,
uh,
was on one of those fucking things.
Might not have been faced it.
Dad,
I got a couple of other ones too.
I shouldn't never watched those though.
That's what I don't know.
Do you think that it's bad that you become desensitized?
Cause I'm not desensitized to it in real life.
You know?
What do you think it's good for your soul?
Like I think,
I think after I saw at the,
that'd be heading video,
the famous Iraqi be heading guy.
I think after seeing that,
I'm like,
you know what?
I'm cutting myself off of that and just not gonna to do that anymore.
There's no reason I don't need to see it.
I've see what it looks like.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm in agreement.
I still wash it and not all the time.
Most of the time I'm,
I'm,
most of the time I'm avoiding it,
but every now and then I'll get stupid and I just get weak because it's
something that,
it's a little bit of that,
a little bit of,
I don't have anything particular that I need to be looking at,
so I just decide,
hmm.
Let me see what the fuck's on this.
Let me see what's on that page and then I'll see it.
I'll,
all right,
let's click it.
Let's just click it.
Let's see what it,
what it is.
You know what?
I think the best movie for you ever is.
If they made like a horror movie,
kind of like a free Friday the 13th but it was like Friday 13th but the porn
mixed in with it,
like it was like there was like six girls staying at this hotel.
You know what?
You're projecting your own fucked up weird shit on me.
I think that would be your favorite movie ever.
I don't like Friday movies.
Yeah,
I like Werewolf movies,
but I've making it figure out why.
What the fuck that is.
I guess somehow or another knowing that deep inside people,
there's some,
some sort of an animalistic nature that that it is almost like a wolf,
you know you're aware of.
No,
I'm not in person.
Fuck is wrong with you.
Well,
we'll stone exist.
Stupid.
I remember when twilight with the big east always say you're aware of Wolf
brand.
You're going to give me a bad reputation with these lies.
I don't think that's cool,
man.
Poor friends.
You can't just fucking him put shit like this.
Put it up.
Next thing you know,
it'd be on my Wikipedia page.
That's going to become,
that's the next thing on the Wikipedia page.
I'm not saying that you should put in that during the twilight days,
Joe Rogan often said that he was aware of Wolf.
I'm not saying you should put that on there,
but if it's on there,
I ain't hating.
You know what I'm saying?
I ain't mad at you.
I'm already on some man Shit.
You know,
because when they,
when the Dale Wright's said that y'all had some man shit,
I said something about putting it on.
I'm on Wikipedia and apparently it's up there.
Man.
That shit's hilarious.
I don't fuck with my Wikipedia.
So if you want to write,
it's like a big ship.
I got banned from Wikipedia.
I support your fake writing shit about me on Wikipedia.
As long as it's funny,
you know,
just be funny with it.
Just have some fun.
What the fuck man?
You know,
it's it.
The whole idea about those things,
it's silly.
You know,
you're going to allow everybody to just contribute shit.
How you gonna know I gonna to ever know.
I ain't gonna ever know that's someone corrects it.
What if they don't correct it?
What did you get banned for?
I don't know.
My Ip was band and I've never,
I don't think I've ever used Wikipedia.
And then one day just started being managed and now I'm thinking like an ex
girlfriend was like at my house going,
oh,
I might see Britney spears that has nine.
It's hot,
it's mining or something like that.
You know?
I really think that first of all,
you let chicks use your,
uh,
your computer or they did it with their own computer,
like their own computer.
You know what I mean?
No check.
You've got to stay off my IP address.
When you,
when you have a check over your house,
when she starts fucking with your email,
do you get to go,
hey,
well I'm fucking you doing,
I'm pretty good nowadays.
It's like I'm not like some crazy I have you ever had that happen though?
I would assume that in the past,
cause you,
you're always into all kinds of weird shit and date and all these weird girls.
It's mostly ex girlfriend talk like,
hey,
what's this email with your ex girlfriend?
Or something like that through emails to find that Shit.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I had to,
had to be looking to your emails.
How else would she know?
Yeah.
So she goes,
any computer,
it looks through emails.
He goes,
what the fuck is this?
Yeah.
And then what are you gonna say?
Uh,
you just tell him the truth.
I mean like it's just them over reacting.
I'm things,
you know,
like,
hey look,
and just my ex girlfriend,
you know,
I dated her for seven years.
I can talk to this person,
you know,
and then the music starts playing
beginning of a music video from the 90s you know,
like Orange Juice Jones.
Ah,
and him walking in the rain
this weekend.
Toronto is a basically sold out the only tickets that are available for the
Massey Hall show.
And that'd be amazing.
Hall.
Sorry,
Macy all mastering hall,
whatever the fuck it is.
Friday night,
I'm,
the only tickets that are available are like single seats by themselves.
And A,
I'm fucking super psyched.
I'm super psyched to get to Toronto and I'm super psyched to be bringing my man,
Sam Tripoli with me.
Sam The slayer.
Him.
Oh yeah,
Shady Sam triply.
He's a,
he's awesome.
And then the UFC of course is the next night,
so it's going to be their shit son.
I can't wait.
We are doing sow's comedy whole tomorrow night and that'll be at eight o'clock,
eight o'clock in Hollywood.
Wow.
Why do it,
why you're frowning?
Oh,
I didn't know that.
I haven't put together any,
you know.
All right,
I'll call sal.
Alright.
Tell him no.
Tell him what the fuck they asked.
They asked me today if you're doing it.
I hadn't heard it.
Anything about it.
So now we know.
Yeah.
Um,
I might be doing a show at a,
a pot shop in and uh,
Toronto on Thursday night to Tripoli and I,
there's apparently some underground pot thing going on in Toronto and uh,
they have shows there.
Oh No.
Too much.
So,
uh,
that might be going down on Thursday night too.
I'll keep you posted.
Did Doug Benson get ahold of you?
He wouldn't eat.
He's going to be on there.
Podcasts May 11th and tomorrow,
tomorrow,
which is a April 27th.
Duncan Trussell is coming on at three o'clock,
so that should be awesome.
Bitches.
I can't wait.
Um,
thank you to the flashlight for sponsoring our podcast.
And if you go to Joe rogan.net on the right hand side,
there's a link for the flashlight.
If you click it and enter in the code name Rogan do you get 15% off the number
one sex toy for man it is awesome.
Brian and I have both fucked it on numerous occasions and we give it two thumbs
up.
Get the Jenna Hayes wine in support of Jenna Hayes cause she was on the desk
quad pod podcast and she seemed like she was very cool.
She seems like a nice person,
right?
She,
she did a,
she was nice but she did a would it sounds like when she has an orgasm on it and
it was like a minute long or something that it was fucking beautiful.
Really amazing.
She's a,
she's funny,
you know like
just embraces being a slut,
you know and and talks about how funny it is and like whole thing,
how she controls everything.
No music while the sex is going on and she doesn't like big long stupid scenes.
She just likes it.
She does it all herself too,
man.
She's got 30.
She,
she's won more awards and porn than anyone.
It's amazing.
She's like,
she's an Oji Hixon Gracie of porn.
Is that what it is?
Yep.
She is right.
Yeah.
So you liked that.
That was good.
It was amazing interview.
Well,
maybe we'll,
we'll get her on the show to it.
That'll be definitely fucking,
we'd have to do it at your place.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
thank you everybody.
And uh,
we will see you all tomorrow and um,
oh,
uh,
may,
may something,
another San Francisco tickets are on sale.
Yeah.
Cardi more than half sold out.
So,
uh,
all my friends that,
want to,
uh,
come to the shows in San Francisco.
It is May 12th,
13th and 14th.
And,
uh,
like I said,
the tickets are all there.
They're selling very fast,
so I don't want to get anybody to get left out and uh,
that'll be,
yeah,
that's at Cobbs and that'll be Joey.
And I think Ari's going to do it too.
And you're coming to it,
right?
Yep.
What did you say?
All right,
my friends,
we'll see you tomorrow with our pal and one of the best podcast guests ever.
Duncan Trussell as always,
I love you bitches.
Hey Doc.